just looking around us
especially during this time of the
pandemic there's been a growing distrust
of authorities of institutions
even the institution of science itself
what are the pros and cons of
authorities would you say
so what's nice about authorities
what's nice about institutions and what
are their pitfalls
one standard function of authority is as
something you can defer to respectively
without needing to seem too submissive
or
ignorant or
you know gullible
that is uh
you know when
you're asking what should i be act on or
what belief should i act on
you might be worried if i chose
something too contrarian too weird too
speculative that
that would look make me look bad so i
would just choose something very
conservative
so maybe an authority lets you choose
something a little less conservative
because the authority is your
authorization the authority will let you
do it and you can say and somebody says
why did you do that thing and they say
the authority authorized it the
authority tells me i should do this why
aren't you doing it right so the
authority's often pushing for the
conservative well no the authority can
do more i mean so for example we just
think about
i don't know in a pandemic even right
you could just think i'll just stay home
and close all the doors or i'll just
ignore it right you could just think of
just some very simple strategy that
might be defensible if there were no
authorities
right but authorities might be able to
know more than that they might be able
to like look at some evidence draw a
more context-dependent conclusion
declare it as the authority's opinion
and then other people might follow that
and that could be better than doing
nothing so what you mentioned who
the world's most beloved organization
uh
so
you know this is me speaking in general
who and cdc has been
kind of i depending on degrees and right
uh
details just not
behaving as i would have imagined in the
best possible evolution of human
civilization authorities should act they
seem to have failed
in some fundamental way in terms of
leadership in a difficult time for our
society
can you
say what are the pros and cons of this
particular
authority
so again if there were no authorities
whatsoever no accepted authorities
then
people would sort of have to sort of
randomly pick different local
authorities who would conflict with each
other and then they'd be fighting each
other about that or just not believe
anybody and just do some initial default
action that you would always do without
responding to context so the potential
gain of an authority is that they could
know more than just basic ignorance and
if people followed them they could both
be more informed than ignorance and all
doing the same thing so they're each
protected from being accused or
complained about that's that's you know
that's the idea of an authority that
would be the good id where's the con
okay
so what's the negative how does that go
wrong the con is that if you think of
yourself as the authority and asking
what's my best strategy as an authority
it's unfortunately not to be maximally
informative
so you might think the ideal authority
would not just tell you more than
ignorance it would tell you as much as
possible
okay it would give you as much detail as
you could possibly listen to and manage
to assimilate
and it would update that as frequently
as possible or as frequently as you were
able to listen and assimilate and
that would be the maximally informative
authority
the problem is there's a conflict
between
being an authority or being seen as an
authority and being maximally
informative that was the point of my
blog post that you're pointing out to
here
that is if you look at it from their
point of view
they won't
long remain
the perceived authority if they are
too
um
caution cautious about how they use that
authority and one of the ways to being
cautious would be to be too informative
okay that's still in the pro column for
me because you're talking about the
tensions that are very
uh data driven and very honest and i
would hope that authorities
struggle with that how much information
to provide
to people to maximize
to maximize outcomes now i'm generally
somebody that believes more information
is better because i trust in the
intelligence of people but i'd like to
mention a bigger con on authorities
which is the human question this comes
back to a global government and so on
is that you know there's humans
that
sit in chairs during meetings in those
authorities they have different titles
it's humans form hierarchies
and sometimes those titles get to your
head a little bit and you start to want
to think how do i preserve my control
over this authority as opposed to
thinking through like
what is the mission of the authority
what is the mission of who any other
such organization and how do i maximize
the implementation of that mission you
start to think
well i kind of like sitting in this big
chair at the head of the table i'd like
to sit there for another few years or
better yet i want to be remembered as
the person who in a time of crisis
uh was at the head of this authority and
did a lot of good things
so you stop trying to do good
under what good means given the mission
of the authority and you start to try to
carve a narrative
to manipulate the narrative first in the
meeting room everybody around you just a
small little story you tell yourself the
new interns
the the managers throughout the whole
hierarchy of the company okay once you
everybody in the company or in the
organization believes this narrative
now you start to
control this the release of information
not because you're trying to maximize
outcomes but because you're trying to
maximize the effectiveness of the
narrative that you are truly a great
representative of this authority in
human history and i just feel like those
human forces
whenever you have an authority
it starts getting to people's heads
one of the most this me as a scientist
one of the most disappointing things to
see during the pandemic
is the use of authority
from colleagues of mine
to roll their eyes
to
dismiss
other human beings
just because they got a phd just because
they're an assistant associate for
faculty just because they are
deputy head of ex organization nih
whatever the heck the organization is
just because they got an award of some
kind and
at a conference they want a best paper
award seven years ago and then somebody
shook their hand and gave him a medal
maybe it was a president and there and
it's been 20 30 years that people have
been patting them on the back saying how
special they are especially when they're
controlling money and getting sucked up
to from other scientists who really want
the money in a self-deception kind of
way they don't actually really care
about your performance and all of that
gets to your head and no longer are you
the authority that's trying to do good
and lessen the suffering in the world
you become an authority that just wants
to maximize uh
self-preserve yourself in in a
uh sitting in a throne of power so this
is core to sort of what it is to be an
economist
i'm a professor of economics
there you go with the authority again no
so it's about saying just joking yes we
often have a situation where we see a
world of behavior
and then we see ways in which particular
behaviors are not sort of maximally
socially useful
yes
and
we have a variety of reactions to that
so one kind of reaction is to sort of
morally blame each individual for not
doing the maxillary socially useful
thing
um
under perhaps the idea that people could
be identified and shamed for that and
may be induced into doing the better
thing if only enough people were calling
them out on it right
but another way to think about it is to
think that people sit in institutions
with certain you know stable
institutional structures and that
institutions create particular
incentives for individuals
and that individuals are typically
doing whatever is in their local
interest in the context of that
institution
and then you know perhaps to less blame
individuals for winning their local
institutional game and more blaming the
world for having the wrong institutions
so economists are often like wondering
what other institutions we could have
instead of the ones we have and which of
them might promote better behavior and
this is a common
thing we do all across human behavior is
to think of what are the institutions
we're in and what are the alternative
variations we could imagine and then to
say which institutions would be most
productive
i would agree with you that our
information institutions that is the
information institutions by which we
collect information and aggregate it and
share with people are especially broken
in the sense of
far from the ideal of what would be the
most cost effective way to collect and
share information
but then the challenge is to try to
produce
better institutions and you know as an
academic i'm aware that academia is
particularly broken
in the sense that we give people
incentives to you know do research
that's not very interesting or important
because basically they're being
impressive and we actually care more
about whether academics are impressive
than whether they're interesting or
useful
and
i know i can go happy to go into detail
with lots of different known
institutions and their known
institutional failings ways in which
those institutions produce you know
incentives that are mistaken and that
was the point of the post we started
with talking about the authorities if if
i need to be seen as an authority
that's at odds with my being informative
and i'm i might choose to be the
authority instead of being informative
because that's my institutional
incentives
and if i may i'd like to given that
beautiful
picture of incentives and individuals
that you just painted
let me just apologize for a couple of
things one i often put
too much blame
on leaders of institutions
versus the incentives that govern those
institutions
and as a result of that i've been
i believe too critical of anthony fauci
too emotional about my criticism of
anthony evolution i'd like to apologize
for that because
i think there's a deep there's deeper
truths to think about there's deeper
incentives to think about that said i do
sort of
i'm a romantic creature by nature
i romanticize winston churchill and
i
when i think about nazi germany i think
about hitler more than i do about the
individual people of nazi germany you
think about leaders you think about
individuals not necessarily the
parameters the incentives that govern
the system that uh because it's harder
it's harder to think through deeply
about the models
from which those individuals arise but
that's the right thing to do so
but also i don't apologize
uh for being emotional sometimes and
being uh i'm happy to blame the
individual leaders in the sense that you
know i might say well you should be
trying to reform these institutions if
you're just there to like get promoted
and look good at being at the top and
maybe i can blame you for your motives
and your priorities in there but i can
understand why the people at the top
would be the people who are selected for
having the priority of primarily trying
to get to the top
i get that can i maybe ask you about
particular universities they've received
like science
has received an increase in distrust
overall as an institution which breaks
my heart
because i think science is beautiful as
a not maybe not as a institution but
as as one of the things
one of the journeys that humans have
taken on uh the other one is university
i think university is actually a place
for me at least
in the way i see it is
a place of freedom of exploring ideas
scientific engineering ideas engineering
ideas
uh
more than
a corporate more than a company more
than a lot of domains in life they're um
it's not just in its ideal but it's in
its implementation
a place where you can be a kid for your
whole life and play with ideas and i
think uh with all the criticism that
universities still
not currently receive
i think they i don't think that
criticism is representative of
universities they focus on very
anecdotal evidence of particular
departments particular people but i
still feel like there's a lot of place
for freedom of
thought
at least you know mit
at least in the fields i care about you
know in a
particular kind of science
uh particular kind of technical fields
you know uh mathematics computer science
physics engineering so robotics
artificial intelligence
this is a place where you get to be a
kid
yet
there is bureaucracy that's
that's rising up there's like more rules
there's more meetings and there's more
administration
having like powerpoint presentations
which to me you should
like
uh be more of a renegade explorer of
ideas and meetings destroy they
suffocate
that radical thought that happens when
you're an undergraduate student and you
can do all kinds of wild things when
you're a graduate student anyway all
that to say you've thought about this
aspect too is there something
uh positive insightful you could say
about how we can
make for better universities in the
decades to come this particular
institution
how can we improve them
i hear that centuries ago
many scientists and intellectuals were
aristocrats they had time
and
could if they chose choose to be
intellectuals
that's a feature of the combination that
they had some source of resources that
allowed them leisure and that the kind
of competition they were faced in among
aristocrats allowed
that sort of a self-indulgence or
self-pursuit at least at some point in
their lives
so the analogous observation is that
university professors often have
sort of freedom and space to do a wide
range of things and i am certainly
enjoying that as a tenured professor
you're really sorry to interrupt a
really good representative of that
just the exploration you're doing the
depth of thought the
like most people are afraid to do the
kind of
broad thinking that you're doing which
is good the fact that that can happen is
the combination of these two things
analogously one is that we have fierce
competition to become a tenured
professor but then once you become
tenured we give you the freedom to do
what you like
and that's a happenstance it didn't have
to be that way
and in many other walks of life even
though people have a lot of you know
resources etc they don't have that kind
of freedom set up so
i think we're kind of i'm kind of lucky
that tenure exists
and that i'm enjoying it um but i can't
be
too enthusiastic about this unless i can
approve of sort of the source of the
resources that's paying for all this
right so for the aristocrat if you
thought they they stole it in war or
something
you wouldn't be so pleased whereas if
you thought they had earned it or their
ancestors had earned this money that
they were spending as an aristocrat then
you could be more okay with that right
so
for universities i have to ask you know
where are the main sources of resources
that are going to the universities and
are they getting their money's worth or
are they getting a real good value for
that payment
right
so first of all they're students
and
the question is are students getting
good value for their education and
you know on each person is getting value
in the sense that they are identified
and shown to be a more capable person
which is then worth more salary as an
employee later
but there is a case for saying there's a
big waste to the system because we
aren't actually changing the students or
educating them we're more sorting them
or
labeling them
and that's a very expensive process to
produce that outcome and part of the
expense is the you know freedom from
tenure i get so
i feel like i can't be too proud of that
because it's basically a tax on all
these young students to pay this
enormous amount of money in order to be
labeled as better whereas i feel like we
should be able to find cheaper ways of
doing that
the other main customer is
researcher patrons like the unit the
government or other foundations and then
the question is are they getting their
money worth out of the money they're
paying for research to happen
and
my analysis is they don't actually care
about the research progress they are
mainly buying an affiliation with
credentialed impressiveness on the part
of the researchers they mainly pay money
to researchers who are impressive and
have high you know impressive
affiliations and they don't really much
care what research project happens as a
result
is that a cynical
so that there's a deep truth to that
cynical perspective is there
a less cynical perspective that they do
care
about the long-term investment into the
progress of science and humanity they
might personally care but they're stuck
in an equilibrium
sure wherein they basically most
foundations like governments or research
or you know i think the ford foundation
they are
the individuals there are rated based on
the prestige they bring to that
organization
yeah and even if they might personally
want to produce more intellectual
progress they are in a competitive game
where they don't have tenure
and
they need to produce this prestige and
so once they give grant money to
prestigious people that is the thing
that shows that they have achieved
prestige for the organization and that's
what they need to do in order to retain
their position
and you do hope that there's a
correlation between prestige and actual
competence of course there is a
correlation the question is just could
we do this better some other way yes i
think it's almost i think it's pretty
clear we could
what it's harder to do is move the world
to a new equilibrium where we do that
instead
uh what are the components of of the
better ways to do it is it
uh
money so how the sources of money and
how the money is allocated to give the
individual researchers
freedom
years ago i started studying this topic
exactly because this was my issue and
that this was many decades ago now and i
spent a long time and my best guess
still is prediction markets
betting markets so
if you as a research paper patron want
to know the answer to a particular
question like what's the mass of the
electron neutrino
then what you can do is just subsidize a
betting market in that question
and that will induce more research into
answering that question because the
people who then answer that question can
then make money in that betting market
with the new information they gain
so that's a robust way to induce more
information on a topic if you want to
induce an accomplishment you can create
prizes and there's of course a long
history of prizes to induce
accomplishments
and we moved away from prizes
even though we once had used them a far
more often than we did today
and there's a history to that
and for the customers who want to be
affiliated with impressive academics
which is what most of the customers want
students journalists and patrons i think
there's a better way of doing that which
i just wrote about in a my second most
recent blog post
can you explain sure what we do today is
we take sort of acceptance by other
academics recently
as our best indication of their deserved
prestige that is recent publications
recent you know job affiliation
institutional affiliations recent you
know invitations to speak recent grants
we are today taking other
impressive academics recent
choices to affiliate with them as our
best guesstimate of their prestige
i would say we could do better by
creating betting markets in what the
distant future will judge to have been
their deserved prestige looking back on
them
i think most intellectuals for example
think that if we look back two centuries
say to intellectuals from two centuries
ago
and tried to look in detail at their
research and how it influenced future
research and which path it was on we
could much but more accurately judge
their actual deserved prestige that is
who was actually on the right track who
actually helped
which will be different than what people
at the time judged using the immediate
indications of the time of which
position they had or which publications
they had or things like that so in this
way if you think
from the perspective of multiple
centuries
you would
higher prioritize true novelty you would
disregard the temporal proximity like
how recent the thing is
and you would think like what is the
brave the bold the big
novel idea that this and you would
actually
you would be able to rate that because
you could see the path with which ideas
took which things had dead ends which
led to what other followings you could
looking back centuries later
have a much better estimate of who
actually had what long-term effects on
intellectual progress so my proposal is
we actually pay people in several
centuries to do this historical analysis
and we have betting mark we have
prediction markets today where we buy
and sell assets which will later off pay
off in terms of those final evaluations
so now we'll be inducing people today to
make their best estimate of those things
by actually
you know looking at the details of
people and setting the prices according
so my proposal would be we rate people
today on those prices today so instead
of looking at their list of publications
or affiliations you look at the actual
price of assets that represent
people's best guess of what the future
will say about them that's brilliant so
this concept of idea futures
can you elaborate what this would entail
i've been elaborating two versions of it
here so one is if there's a particular
question say the mass of the electron
neutrino
and what you as a patron want to do is
get an answer to that question
then what you would do is subsidize a
betting market in that question under
the assumption that eventually we'll
just know the answer and we can pay off
the bets that way
right and that is a plausible assumption
for many kinds of concrete intellectual
questions like what's the mass of the
electron neutrino in this hypothetical
world these are constructing maybe a
real world do you mean literally
financial yes literal little very
literal
very cash
very direct and literal yes so
well
whatever yes sure so the idea would be
research labs would be for-profit
they would have as their expense paying
researchers to study things and then
their profit would come from using the
insights the researchers gains to trade
in these financial markets
just like hedge funds today make money
by paying researchers to study firms and
then making their profits by trading on
those that that insight in the ordinary
financial and the market would
if it's efficient would be able to
become better and better predicting
the powerful ideas that the individual
is able to generate the variance around
the mass of the electron neutrino would
decrease with time as we learned that
value of that parameter better and any
other parameters that we want to
decimate you don't think those markets
would also respond to recency of
prestige and all those kinds of things
they they would respond but the question
is if they might respond incorrectly but
if you think they're doing it
incorrectly you have a profit
mechanism you can go fix it so we'd be
inviting everybody to ask whether they
can find any biases or errors in the
current ways in which people are
estimating these things from whatever
clues they have right there's a big
incentive for the correction mechanism
in in academia currently there's not
you it's the safe choice to to go with
the procedure
and there's no even if you privately
think that the prestige is over
overrated even if in that case think
strongly that's overrated still you
don't have an incentive to defy that
publicly you're going to lose a lot
unless
you're a contrarian that writes
brilliant blogs and and then you could
you could talk about it podcast right i
mean initially this was my initial
concept of having these betting markets
on these key parameters what i then
realized over time was that that's more
what people pretend to care about what
they really mostly care about is just
who's how good yeah and that's what most
of the system is built on is trying to
rate people and rank them and so i
designed this other alternative based on
historical evaluation centuries later
just about who's how how good because
that's what i think most of the
customers really care about
customers i like the word customers here
humans right well every major area of
life which you know has specialists who
get paid to do that thing must have some
customers from elsewhere who are paying
for it well who are the customers for
the mass of the neutrino but yes i i i
understand
a sense people who are willing to
pay
right for thing
that's an important thing to understand
about anything who are the customers so
what i think and what's the product like
medicine education academia
military et cetera
that's part of the hidden motives
analysis often people have a thing they
say about what the product is and who
the customer is and maybe you need to
dig a little deeper to find out what's
really going on
you